♪ ♪ ♪
- Hayia Sofia, Sainte-Sophie,
perle d'Istanbul et joyau
du patrimoine mondial.
♪ ♪ ♪
nanaugurée en 537 par l'empereur
byzantin Justinien, c'est un des
plus vieux bâtiments sur Terre
encore utilisé aujourd'hui.
D'abord, la plus grande
basilique du monde chrétien,
elle devient mosquée en 14,,
quand les Ottomans conquièrent
la ville et que Byzance
devient Constantinople.
L'extérieur est impressionnant,
mais l'intérieur est encore
plus majestueux.
Une immersion dans
1500 ans d'histoire et
d'art sacré où se côto
le christianisme et l'islam.
CENK ÖZTEMEL, guide touristique
- Je marche ici. Avant, ce mur
aussi existait, mais il y avait
un commandant byzantin qui
arrive de là, l'autre,
un Égyptien qui vient
de l'autre côté...
- Cenk Öztemel est guide
à Istanbul depuis 27 ans.
Il nous parle de la fameuse
upup,
qui culmine à 56 mètres;
sans doute l'élément le plus
Juste en-dessous, les quatre
anges, explique-t-il, protègent
le paradis, tant aux yeux des
musulmans que des chrétiens.
- Si le visiteur veut
écouter des légendes,
ça peut durer une semaine
parce qu'il y a plus de
200 légendes qu'on raconte
pour Sainte-Sophie.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Sainte-Sophie était
un musée dep34343434, mais
en juillet 2020, à la suite
d'une décision du président
turc, Recep Tayyip Erdogan,
le site a été reconverti
en.....
L'histoire a créé plus de
controverses à l'international
qu'en Turquie, où 99 % des
pratiquants sont musulmans.
- Mais croyez-moi, beaucoup
de nos frères chrétiens
viennent nous visiter
ils voient que Sainte-Sophie
est un lieu de prière universel.
Nous prions pour la paix,
la fraternité. Je n'ai entendu
aucun chrétien srerererere.
- Les visiteurs
doivent maintenant
retirer leurs chaussures
avant d'entrer dans la nef,
où le sol est désormais
recouvert d'un immense tapis
bleu. Seule une petite partie
du plancher d'origine en marbre
est encore visible.
♪ ♪ ♪
À l'intérieur, les tours
guidées côtoient donc
tous ceux qui choisissent
un coin pour se recueillir.
-  A A A A A Arabes et
les musulmans du Maghreb,
par exemple, ne visitaient
pas Sainte-Sophie.
Maintenant, ils visitent.ntntnt)
- Cinq fois par jour,
lors des prières quotidiennes
des Musulmans, les touristes
sont interdits.
Et comme l'islam exclut
l'art figuratif des mosquées,
certaines mosaïques chrétiennes
sont cachées par des rideaux.n ,
elles sont importantes
à nos yeux. On les couvre
seulement pendant la prière,
dans le respect n n n n n n nos"
- Ils étaient des centaines,
ce jour-là, à s'être
déplacés pour la grande
prière du vendredi. Ceux
qui n'avaient plus de place
pouvaient prier sur des tapis
installés à l'extérieur.
- Sainte-Sophie re
notre histoire : l'empire
ottoman, la force des musulmans
et de nos martyrs.
- L'UNpupupupupupupublic,
en juin, un rapport sur
l'état de Sainte-Sophie.
Nombreux s'inquiètent
et espèrent plus d'argent de
l'État turc pour la r
pour qu'elle demeure aussi,
encore longtemps, ce lieu
de rencontre unique entre
les peuples et les religions.